Some great conversations happening over at
the David Pakman show. Read it David Pakman
dot com slash r e d d I-T. We are just shy
of 19000 subscribers to our subreddit, one
of the largest independent progressive media
subreddits out there. That's a true statement.
Fact check me. I welcome it. David Pakman
dot com slash. Read it. A few things I spotted
this morning. A post about anti lockdown protesters
harassing coronavirus nurses at the Arizona
protests. Yeah, this is getting very ugly.
And I asked on my Twitter today whether other
countries are dealing with these types of
wacky protests. I guess Brazil is having some.
And we see who is in charge in Brazil. And
maybe that makes sense. But for the most part,
this is almost at least in this form. This
is almost a completely uniquely American thing.
And, you know, I guess it would be naive it.A
to imagine that we would simply be united
against the virus. But you actually have people
who while they aren't campaigning for the
virus, their actions are effectively promoting
the spread of the virus. Nurses are being
harassed. We've seen nurses get pulled into
protests because the protests in some cases
have been actually stopping traffic. They
call it operation gridlock in some cases.
And ambulances can't bring patients to the
hospital, which is absolutely depraved and
delusional if you think that that's going
to help get things opened up more quickly.
So really horrible stuff. I appreciate Portland
hipster for posting that to the subreddit
user. Greg Heff posted an article about an
individual, a New York bar bar owner who has
died from Corona virus who watched Fox believed
that everything was under control, believed
that the lockdowns in the quarantines and
everything were overblown. And that New York
bar owner has now died of Corona virus. Now,
I want to just take this as an opportunity
to restate. There are some people I'm seeing
very anecdotally and I'm not even I don't
even know where they are politically who are
sort of relishing and taking pleasure in individuals
who doubted the seriousness of the virus and
then died or had a family member die. I take
no pleasure in that. And this is not about
trying to baby or nanny state people into
safety. But I just don't take pleasure in
people dying regardless. Right. And I'm against
the death penalty. Even Republicans, even
Trump is I don't want anybody getting the
virus. I don't want anybody dying. Now, what
I have said is if people insist on protesting
and engaging in dangerous behavior, if they
were only putting themselves at risk, I would
care a lot less about it. I still wouldn't
hope that they would die, but I would at least
say, listen, ultimately they're only responsible
for themselves when they do this. But that's
not the case. They spread the virus to other
people. Other people die. People who are following
the guidelines are dying. And that's a very,
very tragic thing. And I take no pleasure
in this dude dying or anybody else who didn't
believe how serious it was. Lastly, Brody
Mulligan posted to read it, something that
to many is cryptic. He posted. Oh, Mr. Packman,
you know, the capital of Columbia, Liz me
responded. We are continuing the Pintero arc
on the David Pakman show, and I am determined
to figure out what country caller Pedro really
is from. And my prediction is we may hear
from him on live calls on the Friday show.
But a lot of people very wrapped up. It's
a it's a an episodic some episodic levity
in very, very serious times. If you don't
know what I'm talking about, you probably
will very soon. Just Google Pedro on our YouTube
channel. Join the discussion at David Pakman
dot com slash. Read it.